hey guys how's it going it's Gina's
birthday so in celebration of her
birthday I said gel let's make you a
birthday cake usually I'm the fan of
having a cake is like the final product
but I've participated in making the cake
as well we're gonna make you a birthday
cake but this is a very special birthday
cake we love our dogs basically more
than anything so I got you this nice
little paw print that's pretty and what
a husband like raspberry cream filling
oh shoot
that's okay I actually hate I call you a
strawberry cake this is a banana cake
it's okay I like strawberry we put real
strawberries on top of it we can do
whatever you want as your birthday just
kidding I would be putting fruit on top
of it let's keep this baby
what color icing do you want cheese the
fun of a puke on orange they had a sale
so I guess we've decided what the strong
fluffy so I guess we're making a
strawberry cake with orange funfetti
icing okay cool
and I wanted my mom to paint my room
orange and she said Jenna are you sure
and I said yes and she was like are you
sure no and then we pin her my yellow
instead we pan in mind dark blue because
I wanted it to be black and she
definitely said no listen to your
parents because they're usually right
they're usually right and like I was
like all right let's bake us off well
we're gonna preheat preheat the of
that's orange maybe the same color is
the King I suggested not that color but
I guess I should listen to your elders
like I said okay let's get three eggs
have you guys ever made a cake before
have I ever made a cake here before I've
made a lot of cakes we do egg whites No
I don't think so well it smells
delicious you're shaking me know what I
just hit my face often pull smelly you
think I'd know how to make this by now
maybe they're all different
no awesome mate half cup oil
we're making our cake together it's your
mark I mean your cake I mean I wanted to
eat a cake so I said John hey girl you
did one and a half no I did it laughs I
know we would get up baby with skids
with skip good
what's that cake mix just like you
should
would you like to spray the pan make
sure you spray it over the sink gonna
get too greasy all over this all over
this place you know I always get in
trouble and someone falls and slips and
falls on the floor this smells so good I
get strawberry strawberry cake makes up
my dough's too much no it's okay
did you get the sign through oh yes okay
good I think it's mixed
June is mixed no no those are those are
strawberries are you just messing with
me because I'm well there are chunks
there are chunks but okay let's do it
make a my own birthday cake make them on
birthday oh it's your birthday and you
know
okay I think this is ready to go into
the oven now an icing us what that icing
looks gross I don't hardly yes so orange
how many minutes do I put it in here ah
shoot well guess what we've got other
boxes thirty minutes
right we'll see you guys back here in 30
minutes
Alexa remind me at 30 minutes to check
the cake or it's going to burn 30
minutes to change the King one's going
to harm hand it to you today what Alexa
remind me on August 27th to buy Jenna
the most expensive thing on Amazon
August 27th to budge on the most
expensive the family Amazon add it to
here to do this yeah she's drunk
John Alexa never reminded me about the
cake so it was kind of like a moment
okay now you come on yeah mr. short I
think it's something overdone I took a
nap Jenna shot three videos that's what
happened today let's see we got ready oh
oh god oh god everything oh no flour
come on this cake you didn't put enough
Oh God
I'm dizzy okay we're gonna fix this when
you use too much spray this tastes like
France
Oh God Oh God
we can work with this we can work with
this
well let me tell you what Jenna's not
gonna be on duty for anymore spraying
she remember what I said you get the
sides oh yes okay good
did you make sure you got the sides okay
good let's see what it tastes like
tastes good strawberry
I also liked you wow I also got your
candles yeah cuz I was like oh god I
think it pizza cake today we'll get you
a better one for your action you imagine
if you showed up you got to dinner and
you showed up with this is my birthday
cake I feel really bad yeah they must
hate me like this is so bad like I can't
believe it
it wasn't my fault I thought I sprayed
the pan but I didn't put too much
because then the cake it's disgusting
only one it's the olive oil one that
wasn't olive oil mm-hmm we don't buy
that anymore all right this looks nice
is there you look good happy birthday -
when's the last time you blow out
candles probably last you go okay I
actually thought this was gonna look
like I really wanted to make it a cute
paw print for your birthday and this
looks this is honestly this is garbage
think about an absolute trap ready all
right go for it cause it's starting - oh
god they're start of wax and start a
dress like this is I can't believe how
bad this turned out it also got two of
her other colors
let me get you a nice Fork pretty sure
I've had this cake in different
variations hundreds of times who makes
her thinking I don't ever want this well
as crunchy hmm you don't like sprinkles
well it tastes okay this inside is good
you know it's what's it's what's in the
heart the campus ah but now hmm balls
alright guys make sure you check out
John's channel it's me Jenny it's a
birthday go wish her happy birthday I'm
gonna wrap this up and save it for your
real birthday on 27th oh yeah thanks for
joining me that this is this cake I'm
sorry about it that's all right I'm
still eating it tastes pretty good all
right bye College game good Cutlass is
like the worst color scheme I've ever
said in my life